Я не думаю, що колись на митниці був такий бідний керівник, як Максим Нефьодов.
Тепер Ви позиваєтеся проти Кабміну щодо поновлення Вас на посаді.
Насправді я розглядаю це скоріше як, певно, нога в двері.
Якими результатами своєї роботи Ви можете наразі гордитися?
Ми не продавали посади. Причина в тому, що ми не домовлялися з народними депутатами.
Президент Зеленський заявив, що в результаті неефективних реформ на митниці
бюджет недоотримав десятки мільярдів гривень.
Мені здається, що деякі люди банально розповідають президенту казки.
Чи вважаєте Ви, що зараз відбувається відкат реформи?
Я б не хотів бути песимістом, але в мене є величезні побоювання стосовно того,
чи є не тільки бажання, а в першу чергу чи є спроможність все це втілити.
Чи розчарувалися Ви в президенті Зеленському?
Якби я не вірив, що в нас є вікно можливостей, що воно є при президенті Зеленському,
я б не йшов на цю посаду. Це посада самогубця!
Пане Нефьодов, Вас звільнили з посади керівника Державної митниці два місяці тому.
Тепер Ви позиваєтеся проти Кабміну. Ви вважаєте, що розпорядження Кабміну
є протиправним і має бути скасоване. Чому?
Насправді я розглядаю це радше як певною мірою нога в дверях.
Для того, щоб створити можливість, коли реформу
можна буде все-таки продовжувати і команда реформаторів зможе повернутися.
З точки зору формальної, то тут є багато протиріч між нормами законодавства:
трудовим кодексом, законом про державну  службу,
тому формальні підстави - вони тут більше ніж є.
Але я хочу сказати, що не йдеться про те, що я дуже хочу повернутися
і якимось чином виборювати у міністра фінансів,
який відверто розповідає, що не хоче робити митну реформу,
своє право щось робити.
Зрозуміло, що якщо тебе підставляють на кожному кроці,
якщо тобі постійно підставляють підніжки, казати про те,
що в таких умовах можна ефективно працювати, немає сенсу.
Коли Ви кажете про те, що хтось ставить підніжки, що Ви маєте на увазі конкретно?
Наприклад, Мінфін погоджує багато сотень призначень у межах Державної митної служби.
Десь приблизно наприкінці лютого ці погодження повністю припинилися.
Я не міг ні призначити, ні звільнити нікого з вищої чи середньої керівної ланки
і митниці. Що це означає? Що є люди, які виграли конкурс
і яких декілька місяців не призначають.
А деякі люди починають в таких умовах навпаки почуватися незамінними
і думають, мовляв, куди ти від нас дінешся!
Починають з'їжджати з глузду або, як я кажу, симулювати слабоумство.
Це і означає підніжки.
Більше того, лише завдяки, наприклад, підтримці
комітету з податкової і митної політики вдалося протягнути - реально, це була тримісячна війна!
- протягнути технічну постанову про зарплату митників.
Це просто вже цинізм, який доведений до якогось абсолюту!
Давайте створимо ситуацію, коли весь колектив буде на межі  вибуху,
скажемо, що в цьому винуваті ось ці молоді реформатори,
а потім  реформаторів знімаємо - і одразу все стає добре!
Міністр фінансів Марченко пояснив Ваше звільнення
і звільнення голови Податкової Верланова тим, що Ви не "не виправдали сподівань",
а Ваша подальша робота становить "ризик для фінансової безпеки країни".
Через два місяці після звільнення як Ви можете це пояснити?
Що стало причиною такого для багатьох несподіваного рішення мінфіну?
Незважаючи на те, що пан Марченко відверто сказав мені в очі,
що це його рішення, повірити мені в це важко.
Більше того, можу сказати, що мені з боку мінфіну не ставилося якихось завдань,
не запитували якісь документи, не просилили пояснення цих цифр.
В умовах економічної ситуації, яка  кардинально відрізняється від того,
що планувалося у вересні 2019 року, ще до падіння виробництва,
до падіння цін на нафту, до початку коронавірусу. Але в цих умовах казати про те,
що, мовляв, десь надрукуйте гроші, незрозуміло де їх візьміть, досить наївно.
Причина одна завжди є.
Відверто думаю, що зійшлося два фактори. Перший - об’єктивний.
Країна заходить, як і весь світ, в економічну кризу - падіння економіки в США і Великобританії,
і також в Україні. І зрозуміло, що в цих умовах є велике бажання знайти винних.
Напевно, в чомусь саме через це зняли і уряд Гончарука,
і всю нашу команду з митниці. Але точно не менше, а можливо, й
більш суб’єктивна причина в тому, що ми не продавали посади.
Причина в тому, що ми не домовлялися з народними депутатами.
Деякі з них щиро вважають, що регіональний митник - це ніби їхня парафія:
я призначаю сюди митника, я вирішую, що їде, за якими тарифами тощо.
Всі ці люди не були задоволені, контрабандисти не були задоволені.
Контрабандисти замовляли проти нас чорні компанії.
На жаль, тут політичного захисту, напевно, не було.
Чи вважаєте Ви, що рішення про Ваше звільнення було політично мотивованим?
Або, як сказав Ваш умовний колега по звільненню, ексголова Податкової Верланов,
що це відбулося "в інтересах колишніх еліт, яких посунули від податкових, митних схем,
починаючи зі спирту, тютюну і горілки та закінчуючи схемами з ПДВ?
Це одна з основних причин, звичайно. Кадрові рішення на тій самій митниці,
які зараз інколи можна побачити, коли повертаються саме ті люди,
яких я особисто подавав на звільнення, якраз вони і натякають на те,
хто є бенефіціаром тих змін.
Звичайно, це сумно, що ми як країна втрачаємо шанс і час на перетворення митниці.
Президент Зеленський ніби Вас підтримував, але теж заявив, що Ваше звільнення
було виправданим, бо, мовляв, Ви - "нормальна людина,
але на митниці все ще беруть хабарі і йде контрабанда".
Що сталося? Ви ж саме з цим боролися, починаючи з липня 2019-го,
коли Вас призначили. Потік контрабанди за цей час не зменшився?
Той план, який ми представляли президенту, який був розрахований на півтора року
і передбачав зниження, стиснення корупції вдвічі, і це вже дуже амбітний показник.
Звичайно, виправдовуватися про те, що за чотири місяці на митниці
залишилися якісь хабарники чи якісь схеми?  Звичайно, залишилися.
Більше того, вони залишилися б і через півтора року.  Ми можемо стиснути корупцію,
але за умови такої роботи правоохоронної системи,
судів, повністю своїми зусиллями її нереально побороти.
Якщо середня зарплата інспектора - 8000 гривень, то вибачте, очікувати,
що в нас всі 11 000 співробітників будуть якимось янголами, досить  наївно.
Президент Зеленський заявив, що в результаті неефективних реформ на митниці
бюджет недоотримав десятки мільярдів гривень.
Ви це заперечуєте і стверджуєте, що Ваша команда працювала ефективно
і серед результатів - і те, що до бюджету наразі сплачують митні збори,
які раніше або взагалі не платили, або платили мінімум.
Чому у Вас і президента різні джерела інформації?
Мені здається, що деякі люди банально розповідають президенту казки.
Є багато таких зовнішніх експертів, які, не відповідаючи за свої слова,
можуть розповідати, що можна зібрати на 100 млрд, на 200 млрд більше грошей у бюджет,
називаються абсолютно фантастичні цифри,
які просто не мають ніякого зв’язку з макроекономікою, із бюджетом.
Якщо подивитися на 5 місяців, коли працювала Держмитслужба під моїм керівництвом,
то бюджет насправді отримав на 29 млрд грн. менше, ніж був план.
Але ще раз кажу: план - це ж просто мрія,
певне очікування, яке базується на припущеннях.
Якщо він не виконується, він коригується. Якщо подивитися на факторний аналіз,
з цих 29 млрд 22 - це те, що не потрапило по обсягу імпорту.
Сподівалися, що імпорт зросте більш ніж на 11%,
що економіка буде стрімко розвиватися. Але відбулося не так.
Якщо падають обсяги імпорту в країні, падають ціни на нафту,
що має в такій ситуації зробити митниця?
Викрутити руки імпортеру і сказати: заплати більше, тому що
міністр фінансів склав такий прогноз, такий бюджет подав до Верховної Ради?
На початку року Ви запустили на кордонах
сканери для перевірки незадекларованих вантажів.
Але Вам закидають, що вони не  працюють. Що відбулось насправді?
Вибачте, питання працює чи не працює сканер - це не питання дискусії.
Сканер - це не якесь обладнання на кшталт мобільного телефону.
Сканер - це двоповерхова будівля, куди одночасно заїжджають дві вантажівки,
навколо яких їде така величезна рамка.
Коли хтось каже, що це не так, ну, можете тільки уявити,
якщо ці люди погано інформовані в таких питаннях, то що ж вони знають
про більш складні елементи роботи митниці?
Якими результатами своєї роботи Ви можете наразі пишатися?
Я  справді пишаюся, що, наприклад, у першому кварталі 2020,
незважаючи на падіння економіки, на 1,3% падіння ВВП,
незважаючи на карантин і перекриття кордонів
абсолютно всі контрабандно ризикові товари показали зростання.
В країну заїхало на 71% мобільних телефонів більше,
на 43% більше одягу і взуття, на 32% більше побутової техніки.
Це результат того, що великі сірі-чорні потоки, які їхали непомітно для державної статистики,
вони в цій державній статистиці з’явилися.
На посаді голови митниці Ви хотіли досягти декількох конкретних результатів.
позбутися старих у результаті кадрової реформи.
Зробити митні сервіси електронними тощо.
Що Вам не вдалося зробити?
Якщо подивитися на завдання, які були поставлені
офісом президента,  міністерством фінансів, Кабміном на митницю
з точки зору реформи на перший квартал,
то в графіку було повністю виконано більше 95%.
Ми рухалися і почали запускати перші е-сервіси.
І для цього треба було знайти гроші в донорів.
І для цього треба було найняти команду,
написати технічне завдання і розпочати розробку.
Ми зробили повністю інфраструктурну стратегію.
І якби Мінфін не забрав би гроші на капітальні інвестиції,
ми точно б до кінця року відремонтували і побудували 12 пунктів пропуску.
Ми повністю підготувалися до запуску переатестації
і розробили механізм підняття зарплат для митників.
На жаль, тільки карантин вибив нас із графіку.
Чи вважаєте Ви, що зараз відбувається відкат реформи?
Я не хочу давати якісь емоційні оцінки.
Це завжди сприймається, як-от людину звільнили,
і от вона починає нібито все мастити чорним.
Казати про відкат… Я б не хотів бути песимістом,
але в мене є величезні побоювання щодо того, чи є не тільки бажання,
а в першу чергу чи є спроможність все це втілити.
Якщо ви звільняєте ІТ-команду, хто буде писати ці електроні сервіси?
Просто ходити по кабінетах і кричати: електроні сервіси! З’явіться!
Якщо звільняються люди, які відповідали за переатестацію митників,
то відповідно хто її проведе?
Просто  очікувати, що старі кадри переатестують самі себе,
тоді ми отримуємо такі дивні результати,
які часто бачимо в реформі поліції
після того, як
95% кадрів перейшли з міліції в поліцію.
Як Ви думаєте, в результаті відкату реформи -
що буде відбуватися в регіонах,
там, де співробітники митниці підтримали Вас і Вашу команду?
Будь-яка велика структура - і митниця не виняток -
працює за якимось такими натяками.
Люди ж бачать, що так можна з керівником митниці,
то що ж зроблять зі мною?
Інспектор на пункті пропуску: "Мене ж вб’ють напевно просто!"
Знаєте, я краще почекаю. Тут же ж не питання в тому,
що я як інспектор піду робити щось там на кордоні погане,
а що завжди можна постояти в сторонці!
Завжди можна сховати голову в пісок.
Тому найсумніше те, що дали дуже поганий сигнал для системи.
Тобто всі митники отримали поганий сигнал:
реформаторів звільняють і мокають у багнюку, а корупціонери повертаються.
Ну, пересиділи вони десь там, не знаю, 2-3 місяці!
Повірте, вони всі багатші за мене в тисячу разів.
Я не думаю, що колись на митниці
був такий бідний керівник, як Максим Нефьодов.
Можливо, новий уряд, новий голова державної митної служби
зможе зробити те, що не зробили Ви?
Я дуже бажаю успіхів виконувачу обов’язки голови Державної митної служби
пану Муратову, і це справді так.
Я буду щасливий, якщо інші люди зроблять реформи у митниці,
податковій, правоохоронній, судовій системі.
На жаль, я реаліст і я розумію, що якщо наше покоління -
покоління  людей, які після Майдану - не буде над цим працювати,
а буде сподіватися, що якась інша еліта, якісь інші люди
вистрибнуть з кущів і все зроблять за нас, то боюся,
що чекати комфортної і сучасної України ми будемо ще досить довго.
ЄС, куди прямує Україна, і США відреагували на Ваше звільнення
і наголосили, що стежитимуть за продовження реформ на митниці і в податковій.
З вами особисто хтось із міжнародних партнерів контактував?
Відчуваєте їхню підтримку?
Я вдячний і західним партнерам, і бізнес-асоціаціям за заяви на свою підтримку.
Звичайно, я спілкувався і з бізнес-асоціаціями. Звичайно, зі мною контактували
і представники наших міжнародних партнерів. Звичайно,
вони занепокоєні тим, що відбувається.
Звичайно, ці пояснення, що я втратив чиюсь довіру
і становлю  загрозу для державного бюджету…
Ну, це, напевно, можна продати десь в межах країни,
але точно не можна продати десь назовні.
Точно не можна продати людям, які звикли думати,
аналізувати, базувати свої рішення на цифрах.
Ви і ваші заступники кілька місяців отримували запрати у вигляді надбавок
за виконання особливо важливої роботи,
це 300-600%.
Ці надбавки були ініційовані Вами.
У своєму судовому позові проти Кабміну Ви вимагаєте виплатити
Вам компенсацію за вимушений прогул.
Про яку суму йдеться?
Це точно не питання збагачення Максима Нефьодова.
Це стандартне формулювання будь-якого позову.
Тому що тоді, коли людина повертається на робоче місце,
якщо це станеться, то їй робиться перерахунок.
Моя середня в лапках "величезна" зарплата на митниці -
це було 72 000 грв з усіма надбавками і преміями.
Я залишу слухачам вирішувати, багато це
чи мало для керівника організації, де 11 000 людей.
Я можу пообіцяти, що ці гроші, якщо раптом це трапиться,
я собі не залишу і використаю якось на користь країни.
Ви просите у своєму судовому позові поновити Вас на посаді.
Навіщо Вам це? Ви дійсно хочете повернутися на митницю?
На митницю в існуючих умовах я повернутися точно не бачу можливостей,
тому що з цим міністром фінансів, з цим підходом до проведення реформ,
звичайно, ніяких реформ на митниці -
стиснути корупцію вдвічі за півтора року - в мене в цьому є величезні сумніви.
Тим не менше в нас в країні справді турборежим.
Міністри в нас змінюються інколи раз на місяць.
Уряди змінюються раз на пів року.
Подивимося, що буде далі. Якщо буде вікно можливостей, якщо у президента,
у монобільшості і у прем’єра буде бажання проводити реформу на митниці,
звичайно, я буду дуже радий долучитися до цієї реформи.
Повірте, що робити кожен наступний день, зрозуміло:
лупати цю скалу, доводити ці проекти до завершення.
І це перетворить митницю з умовно старого автомобіля на Феррарі,
і дасть зовсім інші результати.
Ще більше я буду радий, якщо цю реформу справді проведуть.
Зараз чим Ви займаєтеся, коли у Вас, як Ви кажете, вимушений прогул?
Я займаюся громадською діяльністю.
Я банально шукаю роботу - так само, як і всі.
Оновив резюме, поспілкувався з рекрутерами, службами підбору кадрів.
Ви плануєте залишатися на держслужбі?
Напевно, я достатньо молода людина і не сказав останнє слово
з точки зору реформ, якихось перетворень у країні.
Але, якщо мене замінять люди, які принаймні не спустять все,
що було зроблено, в унітаз, то я буду дуже щасливий повернутися назад у бізнес.
Бізнес ще не звернувся до Вас з пропозиціями?
Я ж так званий ПЕП.
У мене була політична посада
і є певні обмеження стосовно того, куди я можу піти.
Звичайно, в мене є декілька ідей.
Дуже сподіваюся, що якраз, коли період цих літніх відпусток-карантинів пройде,
я зможу оголосити, що буду робити далі.
Коли Вас призначили на посаду, Ви в інтерв’ю DW заявили,
що не розраховуєте на остаточну перемогу над контрабандою.
Головне, що Ви і ваша команда вийшли на поле бою.
То хто переміг, на Вашу думку?
Я просто звик говорити чесно і не звик, як політики,
обіцяти того, чого точно не буде.
Треба робити реформу, і тоді ми переможемо контрабандистів.
Чи перемогли ми їх? Почали перемагати.
Зрозуміло, якщо хтось був змушений задекларувати більше мобільних телефонів,
більше одягу, техніки, це точно перемога держави, перемога
українських платників податків над корупціонерами і контрабандистами.
Ваше головне розчарування?
Моє головне розчарування в тому, що частина політиків
не усвідомлюють того, що зараз насправді є унікальний шанс на зміни.
І не використати цей шанс - це помилка,
це втрачені можливості перед цілим поколінням.
Тому що за великим рахунком, як, наприклад, має сприймати це бізнес,
який вірив у наші зміни?
Бізнес, який почав виходити з тіні. Бізнес, який почав працювати інакше.
Вони справді в якихось сферах побачили, що перемагають контрабандисти.
І це розчаровує.
Чи розчарувалися Ви в президенті Зеленському?
Це ж питання політичних стейкхолдерів, це ж не питання політичної волі,
яку інколи люди асоціюють з Дідом Морозом.
От Дід Мороз стукне по столу, і все стане добре.
Контрабандистів всіх посадять, всі стануть працювати ефективно тощо.
Я абсолютно переконаний, що з політичними стейкхолдерами треба працювати.
Мені б хотилося, щоб вони всі були більш конструктивними,
рішення приймали б більш аналітично.
Якби я не вірив, що в нас є вікно можливостей і що воно є
при президенті Зеленському, при уряді Гончарука, я б не йшов на цю посаду.
Це посада самогубця! Це посада, після якої ти не можеш бути популярним.
На тебе падає негатив…
Погрози перед звільненням якісь серйозні були?
Навпаки! Життя після звільнення в цьому плані стало чудовим.
Про мене перестали писати депутати, бо було враження,
що митниця їх цікавить більше за все в їхньому житті.
Зник чорний піар, зникли люди, які супроводжують мене
з камерами під час пробіжок або чергують під будинком.
Якраз в цьому плані бути звільненим держслужбовцем набагато приємніше,
ніж бути чинним керівником митниці.
Тобто завдяки звільненню Ви стали більше займатися спортом…
Більше займатися спортом, краще харчуватися, краще спати.
У цьому плані реформи - це досить важко інколи…
- Дякую!